[Music]
all right let's go to ryan in toledo
what's up ryan how we doing man
hey i'm doing good outstanding what's up
man how can we help
all right so um
by the beginning of uh 2022 i'm thinking
about paying off my house
um but i'm unsure whether i should or
not talk to the bank
and they absolutely said no
i'm like well i've kind of been noticing
dave ramsey and i'd like to be debt free
and they said no that's an absolutely
bad idea
what was their reasoning yeah i'm so
curious what are they so happy with this
we said we want to keep this loan alive
as long as possible
yeah absolutely yeah and uh you know i i
totally disagree with them i didn't take
the time to
you know really listen to them they said
i should talk to a financial advisor and
i just want to get your guys opinion
well walk us through your financial
situation what do you got going on how
much money is the payoff how much money
do you have in cash
um payoff is about 120 000
and
currently i have about a hundred and
thirty hundred forty 000 to pay it off
just straight up in cash liquid
um
yes
ryan congratulations wow what do you do
for a living man
i currently buy and sell equipment
that's what i'm doing right now very
cool
so where did this money come from you've
just been saving up and saving up while
making your normal mortgage payment
um i had a business that i sold about
two three years ago and i've just been
holding the cash back and just uh just
keep just keep
putting the savings and trying not to
touch it and that's awesome do you have
an emergency fund in place have you been
following our baby steps
um i have not ever followed your plan um
i've been listening to you guys for
about a year but i have not followed the
plan
um
by the and that's kind of why i'm
waiting until the i could pay it off
right now but um i'd like to have you
know 30 or 40 000 sitting and sitting in
cash for an emergency fund but do you
have any other debt other than this
mortgage
that's it that's it
well in the baby steps where you would
be at right now is baby step four
because you've got all this cash sitting
there you've got plenty for an emergency
fund it may be too much to have 30 40 in
there we recommend three to six months
of expenses sitting in a savings account
for emergencies beyond that you need to
be investing have you started investing
15 percent of your household income into
retirement
um i have not i was kind of waiting
until this house has paid off and seeing
how much extra cash it had to
start investing and um i would need to
research more on what to invest in
because i've never i've never been
around any kind of investment
absolutely well be sure to start that
how old are you right now
35 okay so you've got time uh but you
definitely want to be investing in some
some good retirement accounts and we can
connect you with a smart investor pro
you can jump on ramseysolutions.com and
click on trusted pros these are the
people that we trust that are in your
area in ohio who can walk you through
all of your options make sure you're
educated on what to do with this money
but as far as the house payoff outside
of your emergency fund
i mean you're doing great man you can go
ahead and pay this thing off tomorrow
why do you need to wait till next year
you need to not pay it off and
i mean
why why would why would i not want to
pay it off i guess uh to give the bank
more money is one reason
yeah so
you know they they gave me the you know
usual spiel of building my credit score
and all that and i just i don't know
dude listen um i'm gonna tell you what i
would do if i was you if i
walk me through your numbers again how
much you owe in your house
120 120 and you got how much in the bank
uh right around 140 as of right now 140
right now
i'm telling you right now if i'm in your
shoes i'd pay that house off today
you have 20 000 emergency fund that's
three months for you right especially
with no house payment
yes yeah i pay that off today how much
do you make what's your salary
um i don't really know i just kind of
started the new business like two years
ago
so i'm gonna guess maybe fifty thousand
if that a year
well that changes things a little bit so
i
i mean how much did you pay in tax i
mean what did you report last year for
taxes
um
i would have to go back on my records on
that one i can't ryan you know how much
money you make
no to be honest i have no clue what i
make uh in the last two years that's one
of those numbers you should have in your
head
just just to know
so if you make ten thousand dollars a
year then you're going to want a much
bigger emergency fund
if you're making 50 60 70 000 a year
that changes the equation
yeah i mean rough rough estimate i mean
30 to 50 000 years is what i bring home
okay
so you may want to have a little bit of
bigger emergency fund but
yeah there is absolutely
no reason
to have a hundred and twenty thousand
dollar mortgage with a hundred and forty
thousand dollars in the bank absolutely
ludicrous
have no payment do i need to worry about
raising my credit score do i need to
worry about you know anything like that
i mean i don't think about this if
you're never going to go into debt again
you don't need the credit score because
you only need the credit score to get
approved for debt
all the credit score is is a
relationship gauge about how good of a
dance partner you are with debt if i got
a million dollars and deposit it in my
checking account today my credit score
will not change
if i got a billion dollars in my
checking account today my credit score
would not change
has nothing to do with your wealth
it has to do with how good of a
um dating partner
are you with debt
it's nonsense
be done with debt brother
okay i mean i i i mean i think i thought
it was that simple you know i've
listened to several other people and it
was the same situation it's like well
it's a no-brainer but you know when it
comes to you individually you start to
question things so
no and and hey let's be honest if you
walk into a bank and the banker looks at
you like you're crazy and says man what
are you doing you're going to ruin this
of course that's scary yeah that
interest money you are paying them is
helping them build a nice big building
or just think
the chair that that person was sitting
and you paid for
yeah the problem is you know eight ten
years ago they had me in so much debt
that that it was scary hold on let's
flip that around let's flip that around
who had you in debt
i will i i personally did but yeah yes i
i had myself some debt but and then
you've worked your butt off
right they were willing they were
willing to throw it at us yeah yeah yeah
they love you
you paid for the carpet you paid for
that chair they were sitting on you pay
for their phones they love you yeah
i want you to buy your own carpet in
your own chairs and your own phones
sound good that sounds good hey
congratulations man for a free call you
just paid off your house
george we're geniuses i can't believe
this is free john he's crushing it i'm
proud of this guy way to go so good ryan
what a stud hey
listen
of course your bank's gonna tell you
know what you should probably have more
debt don't don't take financial advice
from a bank choose freedom choose
freedom congratulations ryan you're dead
free my brother
and find out how much you make too by
the way this is the ramsay show